five hospitals and Aleppo have been
bombed that was the text message that I
received on a dark winter night in
November 2016 one of them was a
Children's Hospital run by my Syrian
colleagues at the independent doctors
Association I DEA it was the sixth time
it had been bombed I watched in horror
heartbreaking footage of the head nurse
Malik in the aftermath of the bombing
grabbing premature babies out of their
incubators desperate to get them to
safety before she broke down in tears
and I felt devastated fellow
humanitarians and I have spent blood
sweat and tears rebuilding hospitals so
that our patients may live not die
and through this work and made a
discovery the reason that people survive
in crisis is because of the remarkable
work of the people in crisis themselves
people survived because of the local
doctors nurses and aid workers who are
from the very heart of the affected
community the people who dare to work
where others can't or weren't people
survived because of people like Malik
who despite sustaining a severe burns
injury in the line of duty
the first thing she did when discharged
from hospital was to go back caring for
small children from the rubble of death
and devastation arise the most gallant
and noble human beings local
humanitarians are the beacons of light
in the darkness of war now the data
shows that Syrian organizations carry
out 75% of the humanitarian work in
Syria yet they receive 0.3 percent of
the Syria aid budget and what's more the
same is happening across the crises of
the world I have witnessed this reality
it means those with the knowledge skill
and ability to respond on the frontlines
have little of the necessary tools
equipment
and resources they need to save lives
and means groups like I da don't have
funds to rebuild their Hospital the
humanitarian system is failing the most
vulnerable communities in their darkest
hours now at the time of receiving that
message I was on sabbatical for my
clinical work setting up can do a
start-up determined to address this
imbalance and enable local responders to
provide health care to their war
devastated communities we had devised a
simple model source trusted in impactful
local groups support their development
through an accelerator program and
connect them to you via our crowdfunding
platform where they can fundraise for
their health needs so an idea asked for
help I decided to launch can do seven
months early with very little money and
many people including myself thought I
had finally gone mad I wanted to do
something that transformed our
collective anger into something
beautiful and that's how the people's
convoy was born there's a global
crowdfunding campaign to enable eye-dea
to rebuild a whole new Children's
Hospital and if successful we the people
would take the medical equipment all the
way from London to the Syria border and
we did it
thousands of people came together from
across the world to achieve a global
first we built the first-ever
crowdfunded hospital the location was
carefully chosen by the local experts I
da where they knew it would be safe and
served the greatest number of displaced
children idea was so moved by people's
response they named it Hope Hospital
it's been open for exactly one year and
they have treated over 15,000 children
[Music]
we can provide life-saving assistance in
the most volatile places on earth the
system needs to change and change starts
with us all sharing a new humanitarian
vision one way you global citizens with
skills expertise and resources stand
together with the local responders one
where we are all humanitarians putting
the necessary resources in the hands of
those who need the most and our best
place to use them effectively and
efficiently we need to support the
people who are not only saving lives now
but it will also be them stitching their
wounded communities back together once
the conflict is over to help them heal
local humanitarians have the courage to
persist to dust themselves off from the
wreckage and to start again risking
their lives to save others and we can
match their courage by not looking away
or turning our backs by helping those
who are helping themselves and together
save more lives thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
why are hospitals being bombed yeah good
question so physicians for Human Rights
have documented nearly 500 attacks on
hospitals and over 800 medical personnel
have been killed and they say over 90%
of it by the Syrian regime and they say
this is part of a systemic targeting and
destruction of healthcare using it as a
weapon of war
and the thing with this is that it's not
just our problem it's yours too and
everyone's because a it exacerbates the
refugee situation when you have a
decimated healthcare system it means the
next Ebola type epicentre of disease
it's gonna be Syria and unfortunately it
sets a very dangerous precedent that
makes all of our hospitals anywhere in
the world dangerous and that is not how
it should be so this actually isn't just
about money either can do isn't just
about money tell me what it means to you
that 5,000 people all over the world
contributed three hundred and fifty
thousand dollars to build Hope hospital
I think the answer is in that word it's
an hope I think everyone who donated
what they had their faith in humanity
renewed knowing there are people like I
DEA in those doctors who are exhibiting
the absolute best of humanity and it was
like an absolute reciprocation i da and
the Syrians and-and-and many people in
places of conflict feel very unhand
unseen and I think the fact that and
they see things through the prism of
government so when they see government's
not acting they assume everyone who
lives in those places doesn't care so
but when they see that display it really
does Rick just renew everyone's faith in
humanity yeah thank you
[Music]